[Musique]
françois beaudry et ingénieurs il a
donné trente trois ans de sa vie au
ministère des transports du québec même
foulée retraité depuis deux ans un
dossier vient toujours le hanter il en
parle publiquement pour la première fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans doute ce qui concerne la
construction à montréal et à laval
depuis dix ans françois beaudry
s'enregistrent et compile des données
qui lui sont transmises par des
entrepreneurs
l'un en particulier est devenu son
informateur cliquer sur la collusion sur
ces entrepreneurs qui truquent les
appels d'offres publics qui s'entendent
al avance sur le prix des soumissions et
qui s'en mettent plein les poches
cet entrepreneur la région de montréal
m'a appelé pour me faire part de son
indignation finalement face à tout ce
qui se passait dans les journaux alors
c'est à ce moment là qu'il m'a parlé de
deux cols du jour j il costume je
m'explique ces choses là mais ça me
prendrait un exemple concret
[Musique]
éventuellement aller voir soit le
service des enquêtes du ministère des
transports ou même la police
l'exemple arrive en février 2003 je
reçois un appel de 7 entre pas mal non
et il lui a dit demain il ya une
ouverture de chou mission à ville de
laval
je te donne les dix numéros de projets
pour lesquels une solution publique et
je vais te donner des dix résultats dans
le chacun d'école le plus bas
soumissionnaire celui tu vas avoir le
compte au final alors sur dix comparent
à misé une journée d'avancé une journée
avant l'ouverture officielle des
soumissions françois beaudry note
immédiatement les numéros d'appel
d'offres et les entrepreneurs qui
doivent obtenir les contrats
denis delbecq était au cabinet du
ministre des transports à l'époque ils
ont mis ce document la souce été
contresigné ça a été déposée à
l'intérieur de la voûte des services
techniques simples en sport ça a été
confirmée la lan maimiti j'ai acquis à
ville de laval
là pour leur demander de me faire
parvenir le résultat des soumissions les
résultats sont à quelques détails près
exactement ce que son informateur lui
avait dit
[Musique]
de toute évidence il y avait eu
collusion et changement dernier à
mayotte là pour deux des dix projets
nous sommes allés rencontrer le ministre
ménard lui avons fait part de ce fait là
et le ministre ménard était scandalisé
bouleversé troublé et il a demandé sur
le chat haut fonctionnaire du ministère
des transports de référé le tout à la
sûreté du québec est lui-même en a saisi
la direction générale la surdité pas
qu'à l'époque c'était le début d'une
collaboration que j'ai eu avec la sûreté
du québec
jusqu'à ce que je prenne ma retraite
la sûreté du québec veut rencontrer son
informateur mais celui ci a trop peur
françois beaudry sert donc
d'intermédiaire c'est ainsi qu'il
s'initie au langage codé du club des
entrepreneurs le vocabulaire du golfe en
2003 la méthode qui était utilisé un
trou pour s'échanger de l'information
c'était l'organisation de parties de
golf les entrepreneurs parle d'un jeu de
golf fictif pour déjouer une éventuelle
écoute électronique le langage utilisé
pour indiquer que
l'entrepreneur qui organisait la
soumission
c'est lui qui organisait le foursome ce
qu'il appelait son collègue
entrepreneurs à diesse sport deuxième je
parle troisième sparrow quatrième donc
ils organisent une partie c'était le
vocabulaire utilisé à l'époque ce
système il existe encore aujourd'hui
votre entreprise à la gravelle a
rencontré un autre entrepreneur il ya
quelques semaines il connaît bien
langage du club de la collusion
s'ils parlent à visage caché et avec une
voix modifiée
c'est qu'il craint sérieusement pour sa
sécurité alors les gens se téléphonent
exactement ça va vous être plus tout le
monde sont au téléphone il quelqu un
dans chaque club d'entrepreneurs qui a
organisé la partie de golf alors lui il
va décider qui va avoir deux contres
exactement ça je donne un exemple à 11
heures ok on va partir au quatrième trou
on va être neuf joueurs pissos on sait
que dans le domaine de la construction
le quatrième trou c'est 4 millions
envoi est neuf joueurs c'est en haut de
900000 peu importe le prix que tu vas
rentrer ceci avant taxes fait que tu
peux rentrer 4 millions neuf cent
soixante dix huit mille je sais que
automatiquement le joueur qui organisait
la partie de golf est à lui la game
parce que lui il va être juste un beau
du 4 millions neuf cent mais alors car
on vous dit que le tournoi de gueule il
commence au quatrième trou c'est ça
ouais et qui va avoir notre joie ça veut
dire que la soumission a déposé c'est
au-dessus du 4 millions versant
exactement dans l' exode avant taxes
il ya un espèce de consensus d'établir
un pli principaux joueurs
on est comme ça pour décider à qui
volent contre un élément qui est
important c'est que chacun entrepreneurs
et responsables de l'organisation de ce
contrôle haut que lui va voir ce qui
veut dire que cet entrepreneur la
s'organisent pour informer les autres
entrepreneurs du montant à soumissionner
c'est le bureau de la concurrence qui a
le pouvoir d'enquêté sur la collusion
le complot pour fixer les prix et le
trucage d'appels d'offres ici on connaît
bien les codes secrets tous des fonds
secrets
tout est fait en catimini j'ai vu des
codes alfort j'ai vu des codes avec des
chefs j'ai vu des codes et des couleurs
on ne veut être la couleur du papier
comme tout est réglé à l'avance les
entrepreneurs peuvent gonfler les prix
sans craindre qu'un plus bas
soumissionnaire ne vienne troubler jeux
et des études qui laissent se croire que
lorsqu'on parle de truquage d'offres on
peut penser que les pluies ont fait
gonfler leurs moyens note de 20 % ça
peut varier à 10% comme 30%
moi je dirais que ça joue en temps 35 %
plus élevé qu'ailleurs plus élevé
qu'ailleurs
ouais ça veut dire que s'il n'y avait
pas toute cette collusion il sauverait
35%
ça coûterait 35 % de moins jouer demain
à montréal
exactement
de nombreux facteurs comme le climat et
la géographie influence les coûts la
construction d'une route d'un endroit à
l'autre au pays
mais une étude réalisée par transports
canada en 2008 a de quoi surprendre
le québec est la province où la
construction d'une route à deux voies
est la plus chère 11% de plus qu'en
ontario et 43 % de plus que la moyenne
canadienne
est-ce que la collusion entre
entrepreneurs pourraient jouer un rôle
dans ces disparités
est ce que les prix sont complètement
gonflé absolument mon effort matin me
parlait de contrat de 6 millions 6
millions quelques 5000 qui est sorti à 8
millions quelques 5000 alors vous pouvez
imaginer l'ampleur
c'est si vous permettez l'expression
c'est presque bar ouvert
l'effet encore plus pervers de ce
système c'est que les prix gonflés
deviendrait la norme de référence que ce
soit l'ingénieur qui prépare un projet
avec toute la meilleure foi du monde il
est obligé de prendre des prix moyens
qui sont sortis au cours des dernières
années au fil des ans et ces montants là
ont été gonflés artificiellement les
intérêts en jeu sont énormes
gare à celui qui voudrait troubler ce
système permet réellement fermé
réellement fermé et c'est qui ce que ben
là c'est qui ce club-là moi je dis que
c'est des entrepreneurs sur mafia je
dirais que c'est pire que la mafia je
dirais que c'est paix de l'âme avions
les surveille si vous allez
soumissionner et appel ni appel
continuellement si automatiquement on
répond pas au téléphone
le premier coup de téléphone qui donne
là pour dire regarde dans back dans le
tournoi de golf où tu te désiste de la
job si tu réponds pour outrage aux
sous-entendus tireur je vais y penser
l'eau c'est infernal les téléphones au
bureau ça n'arrête pour juste que je
dirais la veille que la soumission vos
vrais là après ça c'est quelqu'un qui se
présente au bureau avec un numéro de
téléphone
là tu appelles ça price sinon rien c'est
de l'hôpital que ce mot faire c'est pas
un tournoi de golf puis c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne
[Musique]
alors si je comprends bien actuellement
c'est dangereux extrêmement dangereux
pour les gens qui veulent aller jouer
dans la talent de ce que vous appelez de
ce club d'entrepreneurs exactement ça
parce que y'a pas un entrepreneur même
si on a la job de même atteint n ya pas
un entrepreneur qui vont dire je vois
réussir à faire les travaux jusqu'à la
fin la fin du contrat c'est impossible
ça se fait pas parce que tu avoir plein
de bad autant sûreté équipements sur le
matériel autant sur le corps humain
parce que d'insoumission hors budget
[Musique]
c'est quand même une industrie qui est
relativement en dur il ya des gens qui
ont pas pour leur sécurité la sécurité
de leurs familles ce que je pourrais le
dire ces gens-là sommes évidemment là
c'est qu'à un moment donné on devra
prendre une décision
et puis rapporter les faits l'euro aux
autorités compétentes
le bureau de la concurrence comme la
sûreté du québec ont besoin
d'informateur clé mais rares sont ceux
qui parlent bien aux ja contre et ceux
qui s'y abreuvent généralement ne
viennent pas nous voir ceux qui sont
exclus des fois vont ils ne voient ce
qu'ils sévissent certains web contrecoup
de cela mais ils vont venir nous voir
quand elle mais qui sont fait une place
dans la loge généralement ces gens-là
stiles
l'informateur de france aux broderies
désiré aussi garder l'anonymat parce que
l'entrepreneur gagner non seulement pour
son entreprise mais même journée et
aient été physiques
[Musique]
la famille dubé connaît bien la
collusion les problèmes de leur
entreprise d'excavation commencé il ya
dix ans c'était au moment de
soumissionner pour le contrat de
déneigement de l'autoroute ville-marie à
montréal il ya des contracteurs qui nous
avait mardi de positionner parce que ça
pouvait être comme dangereux pour nous
au le jour venu yvan dubé est quand même
allé déposer sa soumission ministère des
transports pendant ce temps son père
reçoit une visite peut il rendre mon
bureau font n'importe quoi
les enfants y retourne
on nous parle de ses missions et youri
dit de postures attend docteure gobbi
jim manley et unis nous voir piétons
dont l'oeuvre pu
tu ne te suivre custody les dubé ne se
laisse pas intimider
ils déposent leur soumission et
obtiennent le contrat on ouvre à la
soumission puis on est à + bosnie
scianna la deuxième plus bas
soumissionnaire à l'époque lui et un
million nous on était en manteau de 640
milles jeu.il haute et un million le
contre est destiné à l'autre entreprise
leur calvaire n'était pas terminée il
est arrivé lors de la première opération
soufflage autre morceau de mât dans la
neige pour sa réponse en est qui souffle
au dessus puis on a ramassé des gros
cubes de cela on avait tous baiser sous
l'amas cols seront âpres et ardues que
ça menait de la concurrence plus
convaincus par stamos et dénis gros
blocs de béton c'était pas ça tombe bien
c'était la manière réseaux capables nous
a gâtés au pied du mur
le bureau de la concurrence a fait
enquête et les six autres compagnies
rivales ont plaidé coupables à des
accusations de complot pour réduire la
concurrence et six entreprises coupables
se sont partagé une amende de près d'un
million $
combien de ceux et porté notre attention
c'est difficile à évaluer
c'est ce que lorsque les entreprises
décident de se concerter puis fixer les
offres
ils doivent certainement pensé c'est là
à la possibilité que manquant qu'elle
ait la possibilité de se faire de se
reprendre
c'est le jeu de la marne versus le
bénéfice
des condamnations comme celle qui a
donné raison à la famille dubé il n'y en
a eu que 24 depuis 15 ans pour tout le
canada
que ce soit un complot un truquage
d'offres c'est difficile non seulement à
les détecter mais allez prouver la
collusion est difficile à prouver
tout comme les représailles dont peuvent
être victimes les entrepreneurs
d'ailleurs aucune accusation n'a été
portée pour l'incident qui a détruit
d'équipement dé dubé ni pour les menaces
au québec c'est le far west tout est
arrangé d'avancé et si vous avez le
malheur d'obtenir un chantier qui
n'était pas destiné pour vous par les sd
qui régissent vous êtes dans marde
complètement
paul sauvé dirige une entreprise de
maçonnerie il a été l'un des premiers
dans l'industrie a levé le voile sur des
pratiques criminelles dans la
construction
il a eu des problèmes avec les hells
angels dans sa propre entreprise
puis il a dû composer avec d'autres
criminels
après avoir obtenu le contrat de
réfection du toit de l'hôtel de ville de
montréal l'industrie qui et qui trouble
fête
triki géré par la mafia quant à moi
c'est une industrie qui est qui est sale
qui a besoin d'un remaniement total et
complet
paul sauvé n'est pas le seul à
l'affirmer je suis vraiment désolé de le
dire pour vous près de la communauté
italienne de montréal mais il faut
appeler les choses par leur nom
c'est la mafia montréalaise le mafia
italienne montréalaise qui contrôle ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de la ville
de montréal alors je parle toujours dans
le domaine de la construction routière
ya un contrôle
selon ce qu'on en déduit lors de la peu
près 80% des contrats
[Musique]
on a un groupe spécifiquement montréal
qui contrôle jusqu'à une certaine sorte
l'approvisionnement sur l'île qui se
passent un à tour de rôle des conforts
on les nomme les fables du sporting
c'est comme une mauvaise course de poney
à blue band sous les prix c'est à mon
tour 7 à santos et à l'auto la mafia
prendrait même son pourcentage une
ristourne que doivent lui payer les
entrepreneurs qui obtiennent des
contrats d'importance à montréal
[Musique]
à l'époque on parlait de 3% qui était
remis en argent sun
quant à mes valises argent qui est remis
à un interlocuteur à un endroit donné
selon plusieurs sources plusieurs
transactions ont eu lieu dans le
stationnement d'orange uleb dans l'ouest
de montréal
à quoi sert ce 3% remis à la mafia
françois beaudry a sa petite idée
là-dessus ce qui est dit de façon
systématique
c'est que c'est pour la politique
personnellement je n'y crois pour moi
je pense que tout simplement sur toi
pour sa lovemore dans la poche du
mafioso et pied
d'autres affirment que cette somme
serait destinée aux caisse occulte de
partis politiques
après avoir obtenu le contrat de l'hôtel
de ville de montréal paul sauvé avoue
avoir fait des chèques à la demande d'un
membre du clan rizutto il a versé plus
de 40000 dollars à des intermédiaires
le maire gérald tremblay répond à toutes
les allégations de cette nature de la
même façon toutes les fois que j'ai été
informé d'allégations j'ai fait des
enquêtes internes et par la suite s'il y
avait matière à pour accor a continué je
donnais aux autorités compétentes
le maire gérald tremblay a mandaté un
groupe de travail qui cherche des
solutions à ce fléau
à ce jour aucune enquête policière n'a
démontré de corruption chez les élus à
la ville de montréal
mais il est clair dans l'esprit de la
famille dubé que les entrepreneurs ont
besoin d'une certaine complaisance voire
d'une complicité de la part de certains
fonctionnaires
dans leur cas c'était dans un bureau
régional du ministère des transports
là quand j'ai déposé ma soumission ya un
monsieur là l'intérieur du ministère un
fonctionnaire qui menu m'a cherchée dans
sa salle il m'emmenait d'un bureau en
arrière il m'a demandé de retirer ma
soumission de dos
[Musique]
le fonctionnaire en question n'a jamais
été accusé il avait pris sa retraite au
moment où les faits ont été connus pour
cet entrepreneur aussi il semble évident
que la collaboration du donneur
d'ouvragé nécessaire donc vous venu
d'aller chercher on vient d'aller
chercher les pour revenir au bureau vous
avez encore rien fait absolument rien
donc quelqu'un qui dit à la personne
coûté des fans que telle compagnie nous
chercher les plans exactement sur donc
ça prenne une connivence d'une
complicité à la ville exactement
exactement ce alors quelqu'un informe et
il ya cliquer kivu téléphone tout c'est
après tout ce tapage vous dirait on n'a
même pas le temps puis on n'a pas le
temps d'arriver que le téléphone sonne
t'oublies les plains tu oublies ce
tournoi de golf là il est organisé
[Musique]
pour les fans ce reportage nous avons
fait des demandes d'entrevue à gilles
vaillancourt le maire de laval et à
julie boulet la ministre des transports
ils ont refusé ce dossier semble
embarrasser les politiciens je pense que
c'est un secret de polichinelle à
l'effet que la construction le secteur
de la construction
donc quand on parle de 20 des
entrepreneurs ou des firmes d'ingénieurs
sont sollicités par tous les
participants des partis politiques pour
contribuer au financement de la
démocratie en bulles mais est ce que
c'est un mauvais système séparément à
répondre à ça j'ai pas les qualités
requises mais on peut s'interroger
moi je pense que les doigts pointés du
doigt partis politiques plus que l'autre
françois beaudry croyait détenir une
preuve qui convaincrait les autorités en
2003 après une enquête de la sûreté du
québec
le dossier a été transmis au bureau de
la concurrence et six ans plus tard
aucune accusation n'a encore été portée
ni l'un ni l'autre n'a voulu commenter
cette enquête en particulier mais ils
insistent sur leurs besoins
d'informateur clé
plus on a de renseignement plus on peut
faire des liens puis on fait des liens
plus on peut faire des enquêtes majeures
comme on a fait dans plusieurs hautes
sphères de criminels des dernières
années
ma motivation première c'est que ce bout
cielo soit traitée un peu comme ce qui
est arrivé avec le dossier des hells
angels les médias ont agit un peu comme
catalyseur pour faire en sorte que
l'opinion publique et agissent et exige
en quelque sorte que qui est d'aider des
effectifs des réchauds ce suffisant pour
contrer ce fléau
ces gens là ce n'est pas d'aider des
bandits de ruelle ce sont des gens bien
établie qui ont beaucoup de pouvoir
donc il faut briser ce sens ce système
de complaisance quand le système aura
été révélé au grand jour seulement ce
jour là françois beaudry ira à la pêche
tranquille